so welcome back everyone uh now that we
understand what blockchains are used for
let's talk a little bit about how do we
actually
protect data on the blockchain so it's
not publicly available to the whole
world
so again just to review if we look at a
bitcoin transaction
you realize that the source addresses
are written in the clear on the
blockchain and all the amounts are
written in the clear on the blockchain
as well so everyone can see who is
paying who
one thing that i need to point out is
this may look like it's hiding the
identity of the pair and it's hiding the
identity of who's being paid but in
reality there's actually a lot of work
to show that in fact it's very difficult
to figure out the physical identity
associated with this address there are
many papers to do it and in fact there
are companies that analyze the
blockchain and map these addresses to
physical entities so really it's uh
there's no privacy here right in a sense
you know exactly who paid who and how
much at any given time
so this is a problem for businesses and
that you can see who the pair is who the
payees and what the amounts were in
particular if uh
stanford university wanted to pay my
salary in bitcoin everybody in the world
will be able to see exactly what my
salary is so that's kind of a problem um
similarly in a supply chain case you
know if ford wanted to buy tires from
its supplier and pay in bitcoin
everybody would see exactly how much
ford is paying for its for its tires so
that is kind of unusable by businesses
it's kind of a mismatch with business
needs and so the question is what can we
do
and it turns out there's a beautiful
beautiful idea
that allows you to actually retain the
property of public verifiability
but do so in a way that does not violate
privacy yeah so we preserve privacy
so this is an idea that's called
confidential transactions and the idea
is rather than writing the amounts on
the blockchain in the clear
what we're going to do is we're going to
replace all these amounts by what's
called the commitment to the amounts
okay so what is a commitment a
commitment is basically
a way to represent data in a way that no
one can know what the data is
but the person who wrote the data can no
longer change it yeah so
they're committed to a particular value
even though no one knows what the value
is so you know it's one of these things
where i can't actually give a talk
without doing a little bit of math so
you can see that the amount that was
written was five three three and so on
and so forth instead of writing five
three three in the clear what we're
gonna do is we're gonna write the number
five three three instead of sort of an
exponent and then we're going to hide
this value by blinding it with another
value so all that is sort of what's
called a cryptographic commitment i'm
not going to get into the details of
that i'll just tell you there's a
standard cryptographic commitment called
the pedersen commitment
again you can look this up if you want
to read more about how pedestrian
commitments work but effectively the way
we commit to a value is uh we put the
value in the exponent and then we
blinded by a random uh by a random value
so that the commitment itself the
commitment is this uh number that we get
over here the commitment itself reveals
nothing about the value v
but at the same time there is no way to
commit to a different value so the
committer is bound to the number v
great so now basically the the amounts
are no longer visible on the blockchain
um and yet all the uh amounts are
committed to so we can all the the
people who wrote these transactions
cannot change the amounts but there's no
way for them for anyone to know what the
amounts are
so this is great
unfortunately it looks like now we lose
the ability to verify to validate
transactions right so normally when we
validate a transaction we have to check
that the sum of the inputs is equal to
the sum of the outputs right that's what
transaction validity means yeah the
amount of money that came in is equal to
the amount of money came out plus
potentially a fee
and that basically guarantees that no
money gets minted and no money is lost
but now that all the values are hidden
how do we know that this equation
actually holds
everything is hidden so how do we verify
it well this is one of these beautiful
applications of cryptography
where we're going to use a mechanism
called a zero knowledge proof
uh which we discussed at quite a bit of
length in our in our crypto courses but
here i'm just going to assert there is
such a thing called the zero knowledge
proof that allows us to prove that this
equation star actually holds without
actually revealing anything else about
the equation so anyone looking at the
transaction can verify that the equality
holds but they learn nothing about the
actual values that's what a zero
knowledge proof allows you to do i know
it sounds kind of magical but there is a
way to actually do this and do it quite
efficiently yeah so what we do we prove
in zero knowledge is first of all the
equality holds and second of all that in
fact all the numbers are positive yeah
and positive i mean in this range it's
kind of interesting if you were able to
kind of convince someone that the
equality holds but one of the output
values was negative
that turns out to basically you can use
that to mint money out of thin air and
nobody no one would know that that's
actually happening so proving that all
the values are positive is kind of
fundamental to the security of the
scheme
oddly i can tell you that proving the
the equality is quite easy proving that
the values are positive is much harder
and there's a lot of work on making that
more efficient including some of our own
work that basically shows how to
implement confidential transactions in a
very efficient way
okay so that's one way so now we've
hidden the amounts so when stanford pays
my salary basically on in bitcoin on the
blockchain everybody will know that
stanford is paying my salary but they
will not know what my salary is even
though they can confirm that all these
transactions are perfectly valid okay so
even though it's kind of fascinating
that even though everything is written
in the clear and we have public
verifiability we can still hide data
from the public eye
well it turns out we can hide even more
from the public eye in fact there are
blockchains like for example zcash where
not only are the amounts hidden but in
fact everything is hidden so even the
identity of the payer the identity of
the payee all of that is hidden so when
stanford pays my salary if they choose
to use zcash people will not even know
that i am that stanford is paying my
salary um similarly well when ford buys
his tires from its supplier if they use
cash nobody will know even though who
the supplier is because everything is
hidden on the blockchain yeah so again
it's fascinating this can all be done
yeah so we have public verifiability
everyone can verify that the blockchain
um
only contains valid transactions money
is not created out of thin air money is
not lost nobody's double spending their
their their funds
so we have public verifiability and yet
all this information is completely
hidden and that's and by the way i
should mention there's another
private blockchain called monero that
has similar goals
so the question you want you might ask
is how is all this possible and the
answer is again using cryptography magic
i wish i could explain it to you it's
really quite beautiful
but it uses sort of more advanced zero
knowledge techniques in particular some
something called a zero knowledge snark
snark stands for succinct
non-interactive argument of knowledge
it's a good name zero knowledge snark
you can look it up
you can read a little bit more about how
how zk snarks work um
but i should say that we also covered in
our courses so if you're interested in
seeing that then please take some of our
future courses
it's a fascinating area and
it's quite a strong capability as you
can imagine in the context of
blockchains because again it allows us
to preserve public verifiability without
revealing information on the public
blockchain so a very useful tool
all right so that's all i wanted to say
about privacy on the blockchain i just
wanted to make it clear that just before
because the blockchain is public doesn't
mean that all the data is public
and the next thing i want to talk about
is essentially the mechanics of how
mining actually works yeah so we haven't
really talked about what the miners do
so now we're going to kind of move
around in our you know a little survey
and talk a little bit about how mining
works in practice